just in the last week or so there's been
a couple of interesting stories from
space um both involving water in space
in one way or another so we thought we'd
have a quick chat and
tell you about those
so the first one is is the classic water
story in some ways which is water on
mars it's something that people have
been fascinated about for centuries i
guess when people first thought there
might be canals on mars then that
introduced the idea there might be water
on mars and the fascination obviously
fundamentally arises from the fact that
we think that water is sort of
fundamentally associated with life and
there's the best evidence today of
liquid water on the surface of mars has
just been released there's a space pro
out there at the moment the mars
reconnaissance orbiter nasa probe which
has been taking pictures of the
surface of mars for some years now
martian years now and one of the things
that they've recently discovered is that
on some hillsides on mars in winter
there's nothing much going on and then
in the martian spring you start finding
these little sort of dark streaks
appearing on these hillsides and as you
follow them through the summer months
you find the streaks get longer and
longer and sometimes they bifurcate they
split into two sometimes they merge
together and for all the world they look
like little trickles of water running
down the hillside this is water now that
you can see running on the surface of
mars which means that you know when it's
it's not there on the surface it must be
very close to the surface and so the
idea now is that if you're finding this
this much water on the surface if you
could actually dig down a bit then
potentially there could be great
reservoirs of the stuff down there there
is a one interesting issue which is that
if you kind of figure out what the
surface temperature and atmospheric
pressure and so on on mars is likely to
be
there shouldn't really be any liquid
water on the surface it should still be
frozen it's very cold still
and so the only way you can actually
make it
that there is actually liquid water on
the surface of mars is if it isn't pure
water if it has to be brine it has to be
very salty water because if you add salt
to water it lowers the freezing
temperature considerably and although
salty water is not very conducive to
life there are actually quite a lot of
bacteria here on earth that really
thrive in a salty environment and so the
idea is that if you're really looking
for life on mars the best bet at the
moment is that they're likely to be
these sort of salt loving bacteria
living in these trickles of water how
come we're never catching the smoking
gun it just seems too weird that we
never actually see it we always just
missed it by a few hours i think it's at
least in part that people are very
conservative about where they land
things because you want to make sure
when you land a probe on mars that it's
not going to tip over when it lands that
it's not going to fall down a ravine and
so on so people tend to pick fairly dull
places to land and not surprisingly the
exciting stuff like running water and so
on tends to happen in the hilly places
and the more exciting places so as we
get a bit more adventurous i'll start
building probes that can actually travel
larger distances on mars i think we will
actually find these things but it is
just this effect that you tend to be a
bit conservative where you put them down
which means that you tend to pick the
dole places so not surprisingly the
place turns out looking a little bit
dull as well
and how come whenever they see evidence
of liquid flowing they always say it's
water couldn't there be other liquids
that cause these little riverlets and
erosion on the sides of hills it could
be there aren't that many materials that
are actually liquid at those kind of
temperatures so there aren't a huge
number of things to choose from and
because both hydrogen and oxygen are
very abundant in the universe
the most likely thing that you're going
to find running on the surface is going
to be water it really is odds on that
they have found water now i don't think
it's not one of those things that
someone is going to come up with an
alternative explanation i suspect quite
how important it is for you know life on
mars and those kinds of things remains
to be seen but no it's an interesting
story certainly
it is related to water but actually let
me start with oxygen oxygen is a very
abundant element in the universe one of
the most abundant there is and yet
bizarrely astronomers have never
actually found molecular oxygen anywhere
in the universe
we can find it in other compounds carbon
monoxide for example exists a lot and
that's carbon and oxygen together but
oxygen on its own o2 oxygen plus oxygen
has never been found before except here
on earth yes and i was out there in
space i meant to say yes and so people
have tried to come up with explanations
as to why they can't find it and that's
where we come back to water again
because the thought is that probably a
lot of the oxygen out there is actually
locked up in water and then you can't
then see lots and lots of water because
that water is then frozen as ice and if
you take those take that ice and put it
on the surface of little grains in space
so you have these little sort of sand
grains and dust grains
that are covered in in little icy coats
then they're very chemically
non-reactive and so actually you don't
see very much going on and you're not
going to produce molecular oxygen from
those so someone came up with a clever
experiment to actually try and and
detect it for the first time which is if
this story is right and all that water
is out there so all the oxygen is locked
up in water on these dust grains if you
look at somewhere where those little icy
coats are being melted away and so it's
turned back into liquid water then when
you've got liquid water you have much
more chance of chemical reactions then
you so you can then convert some of that
oxygen from the water into molecular
oxygen this is a chance to detect it so
what the these guys have done with the
herschel space telescope the esa
mission that monitors the universe in
the infrared
is looked at some star-forming regions
for the signature of oxygen of course in
a star-forming region you've got lots of
new stars forming which are heating up
their environments which means if there
are any of these little frozen grains
out there the water will get melted on
the surface of them so the hope was well
if we look at these star forming regions
we'll actually see that water melting
away and then some of it being converted
into oxygen so we can actually detect
the oxygen
and sure enough when they actually did
the experiment they found for the first
time the clear signature of oxygen in
the data that they were taking so you
have to do spectroscopy so you have to
split the light up into a spectrum and
then because the oxygen molecules absorb
uh particular wavelengths of of light
and re-emit particular wavelengths of
light you can find those signatures in
the spectral that very particular
wavelengths of light from the spectrum
might be missing entirely or you might
have an extra excess at a particular
wavelength even though these are what
for astronomers are quite dense regions
because the stars forming there it's
still comparable to the best vacuums you
can get on earth so no no there's tiny
amounts of oxygen you certainly wouldn't
want to be out there trying to breathe